after months of informing the rest of us
that ukraine's territorial integrity is
more important than our own it looks
like the byte administration may finally
be getting the conflict it has longed
for
multiple outlets are reporting tonight
that russian military units may soon
move across the border into eastern
ukraine there are a number of credible
indications of this including the fact
that russian ground forces appear to be
heading from training areas to assembly
points at the white house officials have
said they expect the russians to move
imminently within days they've been
saying that for quite some time but this
feels a little different which is why
we're bringing it to you tonight
according to politico joe biden has told
fellow nato members that day could be
february 16th that's next wednesday
we'll see
in the meantime at a briefing today the
national security adviser jake sullivan
called for american citizens to leave
ukraine right away
we encourage all american citizens who
remain in ukraine to depart immediately
we want to be crystal clear on this
point
any american in ukraine should leave as
soon as possible and in any event in the
next 24 to 48 hours
we obviously cannot predict the future
we don't know exactly what is going to
happen
but the risk is now high enough and the
threat is now immediate enough
that this is what prudence demands
so a good number of the americans jake
sullivan just referred to currently
serve in the us military as well as in
various intelligence agencies fox news
reported that as of a few days ago there
are more than 300 american troops in
ukraine including some unspecified
number of special operations forces if a
hot war does indeed begin all of these
americans will be in danger of being
killed so the question is will our
troops leave before the shooting starts
this show asked the dod spokesman john
kirby that question today
quote as of this moment kirby replied
they are still there
so when will they get out we asked kirby
wouldn't say
whatever happens between russia and
ukraine the united states will be at the
center of it and that's worrisome it's
not hard to imagine how the next few
days could go very wrong very fast
russian troops kill american troops
inadvertently or not and suddenly we're
at war with russia a nuclear-armed
nation whose military is stronger than
all the armies we've fought over the
past 50 years combined
fighting russia is not the same as
droning muammar gaddafi it could quickly
become a war we couldn't control
our side of that war would be overseen
by the same generals who failed to beat
the taliban guerrilla fighters and
sandals who don't use toilet paper
to be clear the united states military
is superb but the people who run it are
not that's not some outlier opinion it's
demonstrably true
given that fact you've got to wonder if
the bide administration's current wild
posturing and it is wild is it worth the
risk
we're open-minded on that question if
it's worth fighting russia tell tell us
how it's worth it explain how joining a
conflict in progress in eastern europe
would benefit the united states not just
benefit joe biden who's obviously
desperate for distraction from his
domestic disasters but how would war
with russia make us stronger and more
prosperous
that's a fair question it's the central
question
and while you're at it tell us why if
the russians are such a grave threat to
europe the europeans seem a lot less
concerned than we are
biden keeps suggesting that vladimir
putin wants to swallow western europe if
we don't act now they'll be speaking
russian and dusseldorf
but if that's true
why aren't the western europeans
scrambling to defend themselves they
could certainly afford to
germany is one of the richest countries
in the world in many ways germans have a
higher living of state standard of
living than we do
yet after 80 years we are still paying
for their defense is there a good reason
for that
could it be that defending western
europe from russia is a pretext for
other goals goals that remain largely
hidden from the american public
again it is worth asking those questions
and then demanding clear and logical
answers to them in fact it's essential
to do that a lot hangs in the balance
in the current environment however it's
not easy skepticism is immediately
denounced as disloyalty ask why we ought
to fight putin and the hyenas on cnn
will accuse you of working for putin
take it from us we're going to keep
asking anyway
for a rational conversation on this
subject we're honored tonight to be
joined by a rational person the former
democratic congresswoman from hawaii
tulsi gabbard congressman thanks so much
for coming on tonight thank you so
let's just it's hard to know what to
believe always and especially now but
let's just stipulate
agree to agree
that it seems likely we could see some
conflict
between russia and ukraine soon how
should we view that
oh well first of all biden president
biden could
end this crisis and prevent a war
with russia by doing something very
simple guaranteeing that ukraine will
not become a member of nato because if
ukraine became a member of nato that
would put u.s and nato troops directly
on the doorstep of russia which
as putin has laid out would undermine
their national security interests
the reality is that it is highly highly
unlikely that ukraine will ever become a
member of nato anyway so the question is
why doesn't president biden and nato
leaders actually just say that yeah and
guarantee it which which begs the
question of of why are we in this
position then uh if if the answer to
this and preventing this war from
happening is is very clear
as day and and really it just points to
one conclusion that i can see which is
they actually want russia to invade
ukraine why would they because number
one it gives the bidet administration a
clear excuse to go and levy draconian
sanctions which are a modern day siege
against russia and the russian people
and number two
it cements this cold war in place
uh you know the military-industrial
complex is the one that benefits from
this they clearly control the bidet
administration war mongers on both sides
in washington have been drawing drumming
up these tensions
if if they get russia to invade ukraine
then uh again it locks in this new cold
war
the military industrial complex starts
to make a ton of more money than than
they have been in fighting uh al-qaeda
or making weapons for al-qaeda and who
pays the price the american people pay
the price the ukrainian people pay the
price the russian people pay the price
it undermines our own national security
but the military-industrial complex that
controls so many of our politicians
wins and they they run to the bank
you've seen this from both sides as a
lawmaker and a member of our armed
forces so i think you've got a credible
view on this i i just have to ask
they've been telling us with increasing
hysteria wendy sherman and
jake sullivan and the president himself
that the threat here is to western
europe that vladimir putin has has aims
on our allies in western europe why
don't the europeans seem as afraid as
our leaders are if that's true
i think that is a legitimate question
that no one in the biden administration
or the nato leadership has responded to
in any way
it seems they've forgotten that they are
supposed to be accountable to the
american people that they answer to the
american people and yet they they have
failed to answer this very very simple
question in justifying why we are
continuing to send more troops uh to
europe why they are continuing to
escalate tensions why they are
continuing to push for something and in
uh you know making ukraine a member of
nato that again is highly unlikely to
ever happen and if it did happen it
would undermine our own national
security and our own country's interests
there doesn't seem an upside i mean no
one has been able to explain why
americans should want ukraine to join
nato is there something that we're
missing here is there some benefit to
the united states from having that
happen
i've looked at this carefully tucker and
i have yet to find any benefit that a
political leader has used or could use
to justify this to the american people
all you hear is like well we have to
defend democracy we have to defend this
democratic country of ukraine but as you
know very well
this current president you know shuts
down polit arrests political opposition
throws them in jail shuts down tv
stations that are critical to him
i have a hard time seeing how president
biden or anyone can
say with an honest face we are defending
democracy and the reason is because our
own government has publicly supported
these authoritarian actions by the
ukrainian president in shutting down
their own political opposition and it
begs the question
this sounds familiar to some of the
things that unfortunately we're seeing
play out right here at home
i was about i was just about to say it
sounds like their kind of democracy
chelsea gabbard that's about the
smartest analysis i've heard and i
really appreciate you laying it out for
us thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else